Quarante-huit heures à Miami.
Une mission : trouver The Rock.
The Rock ?
Il est pas là.
The Rock !
On est à Wynwood.
C'est un quartier des artistes.
Donc c'est pour ça je pense que potentiellement, il peut y avoir The Rock quoi.
J'installe ça parce qu'on m'a demandé de vlogguer mais bon évidemment...
Et pis alors on m'a donné ce truc-la, là.
Ça va se casser la gueule.
C'est pas très pratique...
En plus, si je suis obligée de faire ça à chaque fois que je filme...
Ça va pas être évident cette histoire...
The Rock ?
Non.
Oh shit...
Aude, on est pas censés aller voir The Rock ?
Ah bah j'ai complètement zappé...
The Rock ?
The Rock !
Bon bah j'abandonne, de toute façon, je le trouverai jamais.
Je vais rentrer à Paris, ça sert à rien de toute façon...
I'm here, Aude.
And I love you.
Oh my god.
Quarante-huit heures à Miami.